when our friends are struggling our
instinct is to rescue them to pull them
out of the mud to fix to fix and if
you're the one sitting in the mud when
somebody attempts to fix even if it's
well intentioned it is the it is a
horrible feeling
just don't do that you're making it
worse
and what true friendship is is not the
desire to fix or pull the friend out of
the mud who you really want to see out
of the mud
but it's your willingness to sit in the
mud with them to get in the mud and turn
them away and say
this sucks
you know and it's not fun being in the
mud with them you don't want to get in
the mud with them
um but you choose to get in mud with
them until they're ready to say can we
get out now